على الطريق المؤدي إلى خط الجبهة في قندهار ،
لا تزال هناك حركة مرور مدنية حتى مع
توغل عناصر طالبان في عمق المدينة
، وافق الكوماندوز الأفغان على اصطحابنا إلى
إحدى قواعدهم
التي اعتادت أن تكون قاعة زفاف ، وهي الآن في
خط المواجهة.
هنا يحدث في
الليل لكن قناصة طالبان يعملون
24 ساعة في اليوم من القناصين ،
نعم الرجال يخبروننا أن طالبان مختبئون
في منازل على
بعد 50 ياردة منا
ويطلقون النار من منازل الناس يطلقون النار
منك ، ترى هذه منازل مدنية كلها نحن
لا
يمكنك استخدام الأسلحة الكبيرة ،
فالسلاح الثقيل على السطح يريد الرائد بولا شاهين
أن يظهر لنا شيئًا
حتى تتمكن من رؤية علم طالبان
على قمة الجبل
، لقد مر شهر تقريبًا منذ أن
اخترق طالبان
ثاني أكبر دولة في أفغانستان  المدينة
منذ ذلك الحين لم يحصل هؤلاء الرجال على استراحة ،
فالضربات الجوية تأتي فقط في حالة الطوارئ ، أما
باقي الوقت ، فالأمر متروك لهم للحفاظ
على الخط
الذي نشعر به قليلاً من الضعف.  يخرج لنا
الضربات الجوية والدعم الأرضي
والمعدات كما يقول ،
لكن هذه أرضنا وعلينا
الدفاع عنها
بالقصف باستخدام الأسلحة الثقيلة في
فيلا في الجزء الشرقي من المدينة.المشرع
قندهاري غول أحمد خامن محصن
في عقود من الحرب يقول إنه  لم يسبق له
مثيل القتال الذي ينتظره
الملايين السيئين من الناس في هذه المدينة
عندما يُقتلون عندما يقتلهم شخص ما
عندما يتم تدمير منزلهم
وهذا يحدث
كل دقيقة فقط تشرح لي هنا
أن طالبان تحيط بالأساس
بكاملها.  مدينة قندهار الآن
هو هذا صحيح بالتأكيد
، لذا فأين هناك لتذهب إلى
أي مكان ، لذلك هناك
خياران فقط افعل أو تموت
افعل أو تموت نعم وما
يبدو عليه هذا هو الشيء لإقناع
المواقع المختلفة بوقف إطلاق النار
للعمل من أجل السلام
لإقناعهم بعدم القتال وليس
القتل ،
لكن هذا أمر شاق في مدينة
أصبحت فيها الحرب جزءًا من الحياة اليومية ،
فمن المحتمل أن ترى أن هناك الكثير من
السيارات على الطريق  مما كان عليه الحال في
السابق ، وذلك لأنه في غضون دقيقتين فقط
في الساعة 6 مساءً ، يتم اكتشاف شبكة الهاتف المحمول في
جميع أنحاء المدينة
، وذلك عندما يبدأ القتال عادةً
طوال الليل
، حيث تخترق أصوات إطلاق النار والمدفعية ، حيث تكون
قندهار هي مسقط رأس
طالبان.  إنهم عازمون على استعادتها
، وتعلم الحكومة أنها لا
تستطيع تحمل
خسارته يومًا بعد يوم ، حيث يسود هدوء غريب
تقول الأمم المتحدة إن أكثر من 10 آلاف
شخص نازحون الآن في هذه المدينة الواقعة
على مشارف المدينة ، نجد 30
عائلة تعيش في منطقة
موقع البناء المهجور
يقول إن لا أحد من هؤلاء الأطفال
له آباء جميع
آبائهم قُتلوا في القتال
فرت روبينا البالغة من العمر خمسة وثلاثين عامًا مع
ابنتيها للفرار من القتال
بعد مقتل زوجها بالرصاص ولكن
لا يزال
الأمر يقترب  وأقرب
الليلة الماضية لم أنم طوال الليل كما
تقول وكان الخوف في قلبي
في الوقت القصير الذي وصلنا فيه المزيد من
العائلات
البائع المتجول محمود  يقول
إسماعيل إنهم فروا من قرية ملجد بعد أن
أصابت غارة جوية ثلاث جثث كانت
تتعفن خارج منزلنا منذ أيام ،
لكن كان من الخطير جدًا أن
يتم إيصالهم.
لقد خسرنا فقط
الكراسي
التي يجلس فيها ضيوف حفل الزفاف
عادةً في معاطف
الغبار الأساسية حيث يستمر حصار قندهار.